WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD ON "THE FIVE."
YOU REMEMBER WHEN ROBERT
MUELLER SAID HE WOULD PREFER
NOT TO TESTIFY THAT WAS THEN
AND THIS IS NOW.
THE FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL
HAS AGREED TO TESTIFY IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS NEXT MONTH
TWO COMMITTEES AFTER HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ISSUED A SUBPOENA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SOUNDING
OFF ON WHAT IS SURE TO BE A
BLOCKBUSTER HEARING.
>> AT WHAT POINT DOES IT
END?
IT'S A DISGRACE.
NO OBSTRUCTION, NO
COLLUSION.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS WANT A
DO-OVER.
SO THEY HAD A DO-OVER IN THE
HOUSE.
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY HAD A DO-OVER IN THE
SENATE.
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY THERE ARE NO DO-OVERS.
WE SPENT A LONG TIME WORKING
WITH MUELLER.
I GAVE THEM ALL THE
WITNESSES HE WANTED.
I GAVE HIM LAWYERS.
I GAVE HIM PEOPLE.
I GUESS HE INTERVIEWED 500
PEOPLE.
2,500 SUBPOENAS.
THEY HAD EVERYTHING THEY
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE.
NOBODY HAS EVER HAD MORE.
NOBODY HAS EVER BEEN MORE
TRANSPARENT AND NOW IT
CONTINUES FURTHER?
THIS IS JUST A HOAX.
>> Dana: TOP REPUBLICANS
CALLING IT POLITICAL THEATER
THIS COULD BACKFIRE ON
DEMOCRATS.
HERE IS MARK MEADOWS AND
ADAM SCHIFF.
>> WHAT I FIND SO
DISHEARTENING IS THAT BOB
MUELLER SAID IT ALL.
445 PAGES.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY.
AND WHAT HAS HE BEEN DOING?
HE HAS BEEN COURTED BY THE
OTHER SIDE, JUST SO THAT
THEY CAN HARASS THE
PRESIDENT AND KEEP ON THIS
NARRATIVE.
>> HE DID NOT WANT TO
TESTIFY HE MADE THAT RE
CLEAR NONETHELESS THEY WILL
RESPECT THE SUBPOENA.
HE WILL APPEAR.
YOU ARE GOING TO ACCEPT THE
ROLE OF SPECIAL COUNSEL AND
N. ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT INVESTIGATIONS
IN MODERN HISTORY, YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO EXPECT THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO BE ASKED TO
COME AND TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> Dana: OF COURSE, THE
MEDIA HAS BEEN TAKINGS IN
THE HYPING THIS AS A
MUST-SEE EVENT.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR.
THE MUELLER REPORT WAS
RELEASED TO US IN THE FORM
THAT WE GOT.
>> HE IS GOING TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF TWO COMMITTEES ON
THE SAME DAY.
THAT'S A LOT.
>> THE 9-MINUTE APPEARANCE
WAS THE TRAILER FOR THE
MOVIE WE ARE ABOUT TO SEE.
>> I THINK IT'S BIG.
I THINK IT'S A REAL BREAK
THROUGH FOR THE CONGRESS,
FOR THE HOUSE.
I THINK IT COULD REALLY
DEFINE THE REMAINDER OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> Dana: GREG, JUST WHEN YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS YOUR CHANCE
TO ENJOY THE SUMMER.
IT'S BACK.
>> Greg: THEY THINK IT'S THE
SUMMER BLOCKBUSTER BUT IT'S
JUST A LOUSY SEQUEL.
IT'S LIKE JAW'S IN 3-D.
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING IT
DESTROY THE MUELLER
FRANCHISE.
EVEN THE PEOPLE THE MORE
SENSIBLE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
YOU HAVE GOT TO LET THIS GO
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
YOU ARE FOCUSING ALL YOUR
ENERGY ON THIS DRUG AND YOU
ARE NOT FOCUSING ON ISSUES
WHICH YOU SHOULD BE DOING.
AND ESSENTIALLY THEY ARE
LEAVING THEIR DRUG ADDICT
WITH ENOUGH SUPPLY TO KILL
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE FEEDING THEM
COLLUSION SMACK.
AND THEY CAN'T EVEN ADMIT
THAT THEY ARE ADDICTED TO IT
SO THEY ARE CONSTANTLY GOING
BACK TO IT, AND THEY ARE
GOING TO END UP DESTROYING
THEIR CHANCES FOR ANY
RE-ELECTION BECAUSE THEY
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE OBSESSED
OVER SOMETHING.
AND IT IS SAD TO HEAR THEM
TALK LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY
TALK LIKE ADDICTS.
OH, THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
ONE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE IT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
HOW MUCH DO WE HAVE?
IS THIS GOING TO LAST?
IT'S SAD TO HEAR THEM SOUND
LIKE THAT BECAUSE YOU
REALIZE THEY ARE TRAPPED IN
A DELUSION.
IT'S KIND OF FUNNY WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Dana: IT IS A LITTLE BIT
FUNNY.
JESSE, THE RISK, I THINK,
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE HERE IS
THAT WHEN MUELLER DID THE
LITTLE STATEMENT THAT HE
HAD, HE BASICALLY SAID HE
DIDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
HOW WILLIAM BARR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD HANDLED
THE REPORT.
WAS LIKE YEAH, I'M GOOD.
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO
TESTIFY.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF THIS
REPORT.
WILL THE DEMOCRATS RISK BIG
BUILD UP AND THEN YET AGAIN
NOTHING?
>> Jesse: I THINK THERE IS
GOING TO BE A LOT OF ACTION
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
BECAUSE MUELLER HAS NEVER
BEEN CROSS-EXAMINED BEFORE.
WE KNOW WHAT HE IS GOING TO
SAY WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ASK
THE QUESTIONS.
IS HE GOING TO STICK TO HIS
400 PAGE SCRIPT.
THE REPUBLICANS CAN'T WAIT
TO SINK THEIR TEETH INTO
THIS GUY ON LIVE TELEVISION.
I SPOKE TO REPUBLICAN TODAY
WHO IS GOING TO GRILL HIM HE
SAID LISTEN, FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO INVESTIGATE.
WHY DID YOU ONLY LOOK AT ONE
SIDE.
WHY DID YOU NEVER LOOK AT
THE UKRAINIANS GIVING
MANAFORT DOCUMENTS TO THE
DNC.
CHRIS STEELE DRUMMING ALL
THAT STUFF UP ABOUT RUSSIA
SCWH?  WHEN DID YOU KNOW
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
WAS IT BEFORE THE MIDTERMS?
WHY DID YOU STACK YOUR
ENTIRE TEAM WITH PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS IN THE TOP
DEMOCRAT WAS CRYING ON STAGE
WITH HILLARY AS SHE LOST THE
ELECTION.
THERE IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
YOU CAN ASK AND I DON'T
THINK PERFORM VERY WELL.
>> Dana: YOU ARE LOOKING
FORWARD?
>> Jesse: GREG SAID THE REAL
ONE RUN OF THE MILL
DEMOCRATS IN THE COUNTRY
CARE MORE ABOUT GLOBAL
WARMING THAN THEY DO ABOUT
THIS.
THAT SAYS A LOT.
THIS WILL FIRE UP THE
REPUBLICAN BASE.
>> Dana: MEDICARE FOR ALL.
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL OF THIS?
>> Juan: I'M SO SURPRISED.
I WAS WATCHING THE PRESIDENT
TALK ON MARIA BARTIROMO'S
SHOW THIS MORNING AND THE
THOUGHT OCCURRED TO ME WHY
IS HE ATTACKING ROBERT
MUELLER.
I THINK HE SAYS NO
OBSTRUCTION, NO COLLUSION ON
THE BASIS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
SO, IF THE MUELLER REPORT IS
SO GOOD FOR HIM, WHY IS HE
ATTACKING MUELLER AND WHY
ARE REPUBLICANS REACTING AS
IF OH, THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE JUST SO HUNGRY
TO PUT MUELLER ON DISPLAY.
WELL, IF THAT'S THE CASE, IF
MUELLER IS LIKE SOMEONE WHO
HAS EXONERATED THE
PRESIDENT, YOU WOULD THINK
THE PRESIDENT WOULD,
THEREFORE, SAY I WELCOME
HAVING HIM TESTIFY.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE REACTION
I'M GETTING.
SO I'M THINKING HEY,
SOMETHING IS GOING ON HERE.
ONE, THERE IS -- THE
DEMOCRATS STILL DON'T HAVE
AN UNREDACTED REPORT.
>> Katie: YES, THEY DO.
>> Juan: THEY DON'T.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T, KATIE.
>> Katie: LOOK AT THE
REPORT.
>> Juan: I THINK WHEN
MUELLER GAVE HIS 9-MINUTE
REPORT, HE DID CHALLENGE BOB
BARR.
HE DID CHANGE THE PERCEPTION
BECAUSE BARR HAS BEEN OUT
THERE SAYING NOTHING HERE,
DON'T LOOK ANYBODY.
IN FACT, MUELLER SAID, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
RELEASE THE WHOLE THING.
LET CONGRESS PROCEED.
GIVEN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
POLICY ON INDICTING A SITING
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT IS ATTACKING
MUELLER.
>> BILL BARR SPECIFICALLY
DIDN'T WANT TO RELEASE THE
REPORT IN CHUNKS BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE RELEASED THE ENTIRE
REPORT WITHOUT GRAND JURY
REVEALED SOMETHING AMERICAN
PEOPLE SHOULD WANT IT'S A
PRIVACY ISSUE FOR EVERY
SINGLE PERSON.
GOING TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ASKED ABOUT
THE MUELLER GOING TO BE
ASKING HIM WHY DIDN'T YOU
YOURSELF COME UP WITH
REQUIREMENT OR OBSTRUCTION.
A DECISION ON OBSTRUCTION?
WHY DID YOU GIVE THAT TO
BILL BARR TO DECIDE INSTEAD
OF TEAM OF ATTORNEYS AND
COMING UP WITH THAT?
THAT HAS BEEN A BIG POINT OF
POLITICAL CONTENTION.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO TESTIFY.
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT TO
BECOME A POLITICAL FOOTBALL.
WHEN RACHEL MADDOW SAYS
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MOMENT?
NO.
THIS IS THE BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN.
THE PRESIDENT IS FRUSTRATED
WITH IT BECAUSE HE ACTUALLY
WANTS TO MOVE ON AND HAVE
DEMOCRATS WORK ON OTHER
THINGS BESIDES WHAT HE CALLS
THE WITCH-HUNT WHICH TAKES
UP A LOT OF TIME AND
RESOURCES.
>> Greg: DANA?
>> Dana: GREG.
>> Greg: CAN I USE AN
ANALOGY INVOLVING GOLF?
>> Dana: LET'S HEAR IT.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE A GOLF
BAG USED ON TRUMP.
THINK ARE NOT GETTING HIM IN
THE GREEN.
THEY ARE ALWAYS IN THE
ROUGH, WHICH IS NOT A GOOD
PLACE.
ONE DAY COLLUSION.
NEXT DAY MENTAL INSTABILITY.
A CLUB.
IS HE GOING TO SERVE A THIRD
TERM THAT WAS A CLUB.
TORTURING KIDS.
THAT WAS A CLUB.
NOW THEY ARE REACHING IN AND
THEY ARE GOING BACK TO THE
COLLUSION CLUB SHOOTING LIKE
150 AND 9 HOLE COURSE.
>> Katie: IS THAT BAD?
>> Greg: IT WAS A BAD
ANALOGY.
RUNNING OUT OF CLUBS.
>> Dana: RUNNING OUT OF
CLUBS.
>> Greg: GOING BACK TO THE
OLD CLUB WHICH IS COLLUSION.
>> Dana: I IMAGINE THAT BOB
MUELLER IS GOING TO BE LIKE
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE HERE.
YOU GUYS ASKED FOR IT.
AND.
>> Jesse: HE IS NOT GOING TO
BE A GOOD WITNESS.
YOU SAW IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE HE DID NOT LOOK
HAPPY TO BE THERE HE DIDN'T
LOOK SHARP.
HE DIDN'T LOOK ENERGIZED.
HE IS GOING TO FACE REALLY
TOUGH QUESTIONS.
>> Katie: IF HE LOOKED
ENERGIZED HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
CRITICIZED FOR BEING --
>> Jesse: WHEN THE LAST
TIME.
>> Dana: OH MY GOSH HE IS
ANGRY.
>> Jesse: WHEN IS THE LAST
TIME HE HAD TO FACE TOUGH
QUESTIONING UNDER OATH IN A
LIVE SETTING WHEN ALL THE
CAMERAS ARE THERE?
I THINK WEISSMAN CARRIED
THAT INVESTIGATION.
AND HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
THERE WHEN THEY ASK HIM HEY.
RUSSIAN AGENT.
HE WAS YOUR SOURCE.
HE HAS BEEN FEEDING THE
AMERICAN DETAILS FOR TWO
YEARS.
>> Juan: MAYBE SOME OF THE
DEMOCRATS WILL GET SOME OF
MUELLER WANTS STAFF
MUELLER'SANTS STAFF
MUELLER'S STS STAFF
MUELLER'S STA STAFF
MUELLER'S STAFFTAFF
MUELLER'S STAFF TFF
MUELLER'S STAFF TOF
MUELLER'S STAFF TO COME
TESTIFY.
WHY DO YOU HAVE DONALD
TRUMP.
>> Jesse: THEY DUAL IT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S MY POINT.
ALSO, WHY DIDN'T HAVE YOU
DONALD TRUMP TESTIFY THAT HE
TAKES THE FIFTH?
WHAT ABOUT DONALD JR.?
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: WE KNOW HE DIDN'T